in the week ending May 20th sales volume
the number of units of beer sold
declined 29.5 compared to the same
period last year while sales revenue was
down 25.7 percent on the same look
this is this is not just a success that
that we were reading a previous article
for those just tuning in talking about
New York Magazine why it's so successful
success is an understatement success is
like
someone boycotts a product and then the
sales drop in the single digits and the
company apologizes a week later and then
you move on this is 30 percent two
months later this is this this is brand
ending apocalyptic the fear
is is probably Rippling through all
these other companies Target loses 11
billion dollars in market value and they
explicitly said we fear a Bud Light
situation yeah you know we've talked
about this before you just touched on it
a little bit earlier
a huge part of this is the fact that
we've politicized issues that should not
be political right forcing this stuff
onto kids shouldn't be a political issue
and your average person knows that
they're perturbed by it without being a
member of a specific political party
even if the Republican party is the only
one which will stand against it your
average person isn't a fan of it and
when it comes to Dylan Mulvaney your
average person is grossed out by Dylan
Mulvaney they don't want to I mean look
a man in a dress is a very off-putting
thing especially a man in a dress who
really thinks he's a woman Chick-fil-A
is doing it yeah well Chick-fil-A is
going to get themselves into some
trouble there but all I'll say is this
this isn't just ideologically charged
this is your average person as you
mentioned building up an association of
disgust with a brand I just want to I
don't think personally I don't think a
guy in a dress is gross it's it's a guy
that pretends to be a little girl that's
when I start to be like what I think
that makes it way more worse I think
that makes it way worse they both are
gross to me but I think that makes it
way worse it would be another thing if
it was in a play and the guy just got
they just cast an adult man as the
little girl in the play I can even
suspend my disbelief for the sake of
entertainment but it's when it's like
people are saying I'm really this way I
would want to question the person that
made that casting yeah
if anything is not just that it's it's a
man you know dressing up an address it's
not that it's a man pretending to be a
little girl it's that Della Mulvaney is
intentionally insulting everyone well
and budweight was asking you Elijah so
let's remember the whole purpose of the
can was celebrating 365 days of being a
woman but the canvasion no I understand
but I'm saying the whole point of them
doing a sponsorship with her was in
their words celebrating him being a
woman for 365 days except what what
initially started this wasn't just the
can it was a video of Del mulvani
grabbing a stack of Bud Lights putting
them down and then the media claimed
ever everyone's mad over a single can
that was sent as a thank you having
nothing to do they're they're lying
Dylan Mulvaney's Instagram post has a
like you know Bud Light contest hashtag
don't move any places a bunch of Bud
Light says thanks cracks it open talks
about their program and how you can
participate or whatever it was clearly a
direct Bud Light sponsorship having
nothing to do with the can the media
tries twisting it and lying because they
don't want regular people to know what's
going on but here's what I see
you name it Dylan Mulvaney is the
negative marketing element you've got
people who are like wow why is this guy
just like a little girl you've got
conservatives who don't like men in
dresses as Sheamus described it Ian who
is not conservative but still be like
this acting like a little girl is
extremely off-putting I agree with both
with both to a certain degree but I
think Dill Mulvaney insults women Dylan
Mulvaney insults trans people and Dell
Mulvaney insults liberals and like
literally just insulting everyone in any
way imaginable and I think it's on
purpose the there was a video that went
viral of Dylan watching some movie and
fake crying and once again They're
laughing in the background They're
laughing at Dylan fake crying and I
don't think they're laughing because of
the moment I think they're genuinely I I
think Douglas hey guys watch this watch
this
did you see that wasn't that funny and
then they're all laughing they're having
a good time mocking people and I think
Dylan's exploiting the algorithm and
that's why Tick Tock is propping up
these videos so the video of Dylan on
Twitter where he's like I feel like now
I'm attracted to women I told my dad
he's like well good I hope you get a
girl pregnant he's like no no she's
gonna get me pregnant huh and it's like
dude he is joking he's a he's a a
goofball like the dude is pulling one
over on the human race it's Borat yeah
it is Bruno it is a person like so again
we we've mentioned this before
but this is what was was we've we've had
a couple I've had a couple Trends social
media personalities tell me the facial
hair removal laser stuff is the easiest
and cheapest thing to do and Dylan has
not done it but well I think that Dylan
is a very good example of Poe's law
right you're all saying that you think
it's an act because he's clearly being
ridiculous but we're at a point where
reality is indistinguishable from satire
basically that the idea that at some
point it becomes incredibly difficult to
tell the difference between somebody's
sincere opinion and satire because of
how ridiculous things have gone yeah
that is true if you pretend to be
something you kind of become that thing
yeah well and and also it's this idea or
the way it's usually used is to express
that things are so out of control right
now that you can't tell if somebody's
serious when they they say something
because even just a few years ago it
would be a joke or if someone else said
it would be joke for example I won't say
state it out loud but we asked a certain
left-wing commentator if performing
certain acts a activities on the male
body uh is gay and he said not if it's
on a woman but it's awesome and that's
Poe's law because that's like a joke but
right beyond that he said I I have no
problem it's Lance from the surf he's on
the show he said that if a man engages
in relations with a masculine ugly woman
he is gay yeah and and Ian was like
that's not cool man you can't call
someone gay because her girlfriend's
ugly like
well so I think you're right I think
what happens is Poe's law is a good
example of what happens on the internet
Dylan Mulvaney goes in hiking heels
wearing high heels and dancing in the
forest and then falling down because of
a bug I think that's fake but kids don't
know it's fake and so they start
imitating these behaviors you then end
up with people like Lance who I think
he's 40 something years old genuinely
believing that is the left and then
going on a public show to millions of
people and saying if you date an ugly
woman you're gay and if you date a small
petite effeminate man you are not gay
it's like okay what dude I hear you but
I I think the difference is so part of
it means that it's indistinguishable I
think that is the left this means all
bears will be surprised to learn that
their twink boyfriends make them
straight
I mean I got well because he well he was
also saying we can't have hot or not
right so it was it was all very good for
yourself several yeah but I I guess my
overarching point is things have gone so
off the rail and the left's morality
surrounding human sexuality in in
quote-unquote gender which is a term I
hate is so insane that it might seem
like someone is joking it might seem too
ridiculous to believe but that doesn't
mean it's not real well do you think um
satire and parody are like are like
satanic no I don't think so because I
think they can be used to highlight
truth but I think that what happens is
the world can become so insane that
something which in any other era would
be a harmless joke is now something
taken seriously so here's a great
example there was a bit in Monty
Python's meaning of life where a child
is born and they give it to the mother
and the mother says is it a boy or a
girl and the doctor says well it's a bit
early to be assigning roles to it don't
you think and I remember seeing that 10
years going going oh my gosh they made
this joke decades ago and this is
actually about to be a massive social
justice issue quote unquote and it is
now so so I don't think that it was evil
for Monty Python to make that joke I
think the direction that our country has
gone in is evil you know you know what I
was thinking earlier today
gen Z and Millennials are literally
idiocracy now an idiocracy was a was a
lot of gag humor and stuff but I was
thinking we did this video segment uh
last week Isabelle Brown had a clip
where this comedian's mocking gen Z for
being unable to write in cursive unable
to use calculators or find directions
and newspaper maps and this will work or
or work but seriously they don't want to
work polish so they don't want to do
work I'm aware and she said that if gen
Z take does take over it'll be really
easy to take it back and then Isabelle
Brown makes the point like you were
supposed to teach us I was thinking
about that and I'm like it's not just
gen Z Millennials too are completely
incapable uh Sheamus and I were talking
about one of the guests we had in the
show
a lefty and he said something like if
you want to cover health care just
deficit spend print the money to pay the
bills and I said okay let's start from
the beginning where does food come from
and his response was at the grocery
store and I were like this was an adult
an adult human male and is what is it I
was he 30s or something and we're like
no food doesn't come from the grocery
store it gets it goes oh my like okay
first you have a farm they make the food
then it gets sent to like maybe like a
regional processing plant where that
particular food item is processed that
has to get bottled shipped to a bottling
plant then it gets shipped to a regional
Warehouse where it's then sent depending
on the product you have sometimes fruits
are directly handled right there on the
farm sent to a regional distribution and
then right to the supermarkets if it's
like uh so I knew somebody who did Honey
one company would go and collect all the
honey from 50 small farms bottle it at
their plant and then distribute it so
there's three steps but no not the
grocery store thinking about that I
realized we're in Idiocracy yeah we're
literally the point where you walk up to
the guy and say well where's the food
grocery store in Heavenly and you're
like no food comes from farms what it
comes from the grocery store and you're
like oh my God yeah but by the way I
don't uh I don't want to mention uh who
it was and the conversation was off air
but it wasn't Lance
was not Lance I want to know tell me off
air yeah yeah and and but but I've had
numerous conversations with people where
I've talked about this I had one
conversation during the lockdowns
where I tried explaining I was I was
tweeting to somebody and I said they
were talking about
food in the grocery store and giving
people money and they were like the
government should just start giving
people more money to cover their bills
while we're locked down and I said right
but money represents labor it's dead
right so if this if if you're creating
the means to acquire without creating
the means themselves like you're going
to create this inverse reaction he's
like what are you talking about that
makes no sense and I'm like let's start
from the beginning where does milk come
from and he said the groceries oh my
gosh this is what I try Supermarket so
so this is one way I try to explain this
to people the economy is like a giant
pizza and the amount of currency you
have is the amount of slices in that
pizza if the pizza doesn't get any
bigger all cutting more slices into it
does is diminishes each slice now you
could be in a situation where I don't
know you don't feel that the pie given
its size is being distributed adequately
so we have to make more slices you can
make that argument but to say well the
pie isn't growing let's slice it up more
is idiotic yeah but then you get two
slice instead of one channel that's a
good point that's lit that's actually
the reasoning when they say just print
more money you're just cutting more
slices into a pizza that's either
staying the same size or even shrinking
and then I and then I thought to myself
I was like we're in Idiocracy it's like
we're here thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time